[Applause]
[Music]
I've come face to face with a God he
lives in the sky and he's a giant flying
whale if you played the game Skyward
Sword you know what I'm talking about
levas Spirit of the Skies is a pretty
awe inspiring sight for a Wii game when
I was little I spent hours circling
around this deity at times coming so
close to Divinity I felt I could reach
out and touch it so you can imagine my
excitement when I learned that breath of
the wild a game set tens of thousands of
years later also includes
levas he's
dead there are many stories in which
Divine beings come to an end but what
happens after a God
dies would they decompose their Godly
forms rotting away to nothing or would
they linger their figures forever
changing the surrounding environment or
even becoming an environment
themselves would they ever really
[Music]
die the short film The drowned giant is
about well a drowned giant obviously
but that obviousness is the point washed
up on an otherwise ordinary beach near a
small town the Giants corpse is a blunt
truth something the narrator and other
locals cannot ignore or rationalize
without any context for where the body
came from is at first treated as a deity
the crowd reverential and
apprehensive but then something changes
this Colossus be it God or Monster
begins to rot and just like that the
spell is broken the town's people swarm
the Fallen Titan clamoring over its
immense form as if trying to reestablish
their own importance relative to the
superbeing over the following days
animals descend upon the carcass as well
hastening the disfigurement of the
remains though disturbed by the general
lack of respect the narrator cannot in
the end resist the urge to climb upon
the corpse himself the fact that the
Giants Decay its decomposition is what
strips away its godhood in the eyes of
the masses speaks to the inherent
Paradox of a dead deity in most
classical mythologies dying is the
Pastime of Mortals what makes a god a
God is their immortality their
permanence the narrator has the sense
the giant will reawaken that something
so powerful in life must still hold
power after death but the body remains
Motionless
soon people see it as just another piece
of trash an unsightly obstruction that
should be disposed of they eventually
decide to cut the body into sections and
haul it away piece by piece the drowned
giant is ultimately a melano examination
of mortality of how any being can be
disrespected and forgotten no matter how
large they loomed in
life it is one thing to gaze upon the
corpse of a God you did not know it is
another thing entirely to know a god
before it falls and know a God after in
the Xenoblade games Godly beings called
Titans are so numerous it's actually
hard to keep track of them all that is
except for in the third game which makes
things simpler by turning all Titans
into lifeless husks that now make up the
landscape the reasons for this are too
much to get into trust me but the
tragedy here is pretty straightforward
here are the shells of beings that you
know know if you've played the other
titles in the series the game doesn't
draw attention to these remnants either
which is notable since Xenoblade is on
balance a pretty loud franchise Instead
The Remains quietly Fade Into the
background most characters don't even
remember what they
were I think what saddened me most about
Lev's corpse and breath of the wild you
know aside from my Celestial whale
friend being a pile of bones is the fact
that no one seems to remember this deity
there are some researchers who debate
his identity but they assume he was just
a large extinct animal not the god I
knew him to be but I really can't judge
because there are actually other giant
whale skeletons scattered throughout
this game when I first saw these I
didn't pay much attention as it turns
out they're actually the remains of
other whale Gods from throughout the
series Lost deities that I didn't even
know about for being that were once
worshiped it's hard to imagine a more
tragic fate these Gods haven't just died
they've been
forgotten one isn't likely to forget the
deities of the God of War Saga in the
current series based on Norse mythology
clashes between gods and other Divine
beings regularly reshape the landscape
the sheer scale of godly power that
these games capture is just astounding
creting countless Unforgettable moments
It's Curious then that the experience
that stuck in my mind the most wasn't
meeting a living God but a dead one
Midway through the first game in the
north Saga you arrive upon the
mountainous corpse of thur though
technically a giant rather than a god
in-game lore suggests thur had the power
to challenge Thor himself a power so
great it continues to shape the world in
death even even decaying thore's body
emits a melstrom of cold that has frozen
the surrounding ecosystem an effect you
can see from miles away his sheer Mass
also flattened an entire Village when he
first fell this idea is also present in
the Greek God of War titles where the
death of a Pantheon member had an
immediate and apocalyptic effect on
whatever domain they had authority over
unlike the other Fallen Gods discussed
so far thore still holds influence over
the environment in his icy cadaverous
grip you don't just observe the power of
thore's corpse from a distance though
you have to climb it and the act of
scrabbling up the side of this Colossus
like I was one of the town's folk from
the drowned giant conveyed to me the
scale of a God's power better than any
of the series most Gonzo action beats
when I recently replayed breath of the
wild I tried clambering up the Leviathan
skeletons an experience that reminded me
just how small I was in comparison and
that even in death these Gods too still
hold
[Music]
power at a glance it doesn't seem like
there's a dead God in the game ju saw
what there is dominating every frame
feeling every inch of your thoughts is
the mountain and your job your singular
goal is to reach the summit as in God of
War the very Act of climbing in Ju saw
feels like a form of worship every
handhold is a prayer every completed
route A Hymn to the Mountain's power
juon also requires you to make these
leaps of well faith for lack of a better
word where you're suspended on nothing
but a rope in the trust that the
mountain will hold you it is in these
moments that you can get the closest to
fathoming the true size of the
Mountain's body to comprehending the
extent of its power you encounter the
remains of mult multiple civilizations
as you make your way to the peak
cultures that Rose and fell entirely
within its shadow it is clear in the art
that these societies have left behind
that this mountain was something they
worshiped to the people who lived upon
its body the mountain was is a kind of
God and this God has died there is a
sense that the present day Peak is a
husk a dried out skeleton of its former
self the wreckage of boats fishing
equipment and withered Coral that Scar
the landscape indicate a vast ocean once
surrounded this region the game's very
title jua a French Maritime term for a
period of low tide supports this
narrative without getting into spoilers
there's evidence this drought came from
human activity throwing the ecosystem
out of balance this mountain was a God
and we have killed
it there is Ace oted corpse strewn deity
on the face of the Earth its name is
Mount Everest actually its name is cha
maluma native Tibetan meaning goddess
mother of the world the name Everest
comes from Welsh cartographer George
Everest a man who famously disliked the
idea of a deified peak being named after
an outsider but the name stuck with the
English-speaking world and so too did an
obsession with scaling this icy God to
today hundreds of people climb the
summit every year many of whom are
wealthy inexperienced Outsiders
following well-traveled
Roots yet chel malumba or Everest still
holds frigid unpredictable power in his
book Into Thin Air author John cower
writes a firsthand account of the 1996
Everest disaster a blizzard in which
eight climbers lost their lives this
event was a tragedy but also not
uncommon since the 1920s over 300 people
have died trying to reach the peak a
staggering onethird of whom have been
guides from the sherpa Community an
ethnic group indigenous to the Himalayan
sub region Outsiders have long relied on
Sherpa guides to make it to the top of
the mountain Edmund Hillary often called
the first person to Summit Everest did
so alongside Sherpa Mountaineer Tenzing
Norge guides face significant
exploitation and inconsistent safety
measures often carrying much of a
client's gear between oxygen tanks tents
and food containers literal tons of
garbage have been left on the slopes in
their haste to ascend a god tourists
have left her body disfigured and the
community
disrupted in the epilogue of in thire
cower relays an account of a sherpa
orphan lamenting the state of the Sacred
Mountain stating Outsiders find their
way into the sanctuary and violate every
limb of her Body by standing on top of
her crowing in Victory and dirtying and
polluting her for many climbing Everest
is clearly not an act of
[Music]
worship there's something wrong with the
Holy Mountain in Horizon zero Dawn I
could tell there was something wrong
from the start of the game when I looked
up and saw these eldrich metal tentacles
spilling out of the mountain like
mechanical intestines a post-apocalyptic
title Horizon is full of the wreckage of
civilization the skeletons of buildings
and cars and lamp posts and for the most
part these ruins feel benign the only
thing menacing about them is what they
imply that some terrible fate befell
Humanity but the ruins on the Holy
Mountain don't feel benign they feel
like a
disease it isn't the exterior of the
mountain that the survivors in Horizon
worship however it's the interior a CH
chamber containing A God Called all
mother to the viewer it quickly becomes
clear that this God is a fragment of
ancient technology one the survivors
rever for saving them from an
apocalyptic Danger The tentacled Corpse
smote upon the mountain side also has a
name although it isn't called a god it's
called the metal devil and once you hear
that name the story of what happened to
the world starts to fall into
place in fiction the the corpse of a
devil has a very different presence than
the corpse of a God in the studio gibli
film nasaka The Valley Of The Wind
civilization was wiped out by
biomechanical weapons of mass
destruction called God Warriors although
most survivors now see these creatures
as demons but in both NSA and Horizon
there are characters who seek power in
these accursed remains attempting to
wield the rotting longf Fallen Devils
against their enemies we're getting into
spoil territory here but in each
narrative attempts to wield these
demonic weapons and in further
apocalyptic disaster the characters
inevitably losing control undone by the
same human arrogance that had previously
destroyed the world it's no accident
that both these stories contrast these
remains with nature framing them is the
consequence of disrespecting the natural
order ultimately these demonic corpses
feel like Humanity's punishment for
trying to plague
God human hubris can become its own
Fallen God there's a decomposing
Colossus punishing the characters in the
2014 Russian movie Leviathan and it's
not the giant mysterious whale skeleton
you see throughout the runtime or at
least not entirely the true deity
putrifying in the background of
Leviathan is instead a societal one all
of civilization that we see throughout
the film feels like it's rotting From
the Inside Out infested with
governmental corruption the film's title
appears to reference the Hoban Leviathan
or at least an idealized version of it
the deity of society one buys into for a
nation to function in the film this
deity is rapidly decaying Wooden Ships
like rib cages collapse upon the shore a
fish processing plant calls to mind a
slowing circulatory system all the
workers inside the final blood cells
dragging this organism along before the
inevitable a condemned house is picked
apart like a beached whale first by
stragglers and then by the apex predator
of a demolition machine though not
technically set in the post-apocalypse
this world seems to have died a long
time ago and is only now beginning to
stink I think part of why the dead
leviathans and breath of the wild struck
such a cord with me has less to do with
the state of the remains and more to do
with the state of the world around them
though it doesn't always look like it
breath of the wild is a true
post-apocalyptic narrative set after a
Calamity destroyed much of civilization
this Devastation is embodied in the
appearance of another deity in the
series in Skyward Sword the goddess
halia is represented by a shining statue
fitting for an era of relative
prosperity in breath of the wild the
statue of hilia is overgrown forgotten
in a half-demolished cathedral abandoned
years ago it's a testament to how much
of the world has been lost post Calamity
I think that's what I was really
mourning not just levas but the larger
abstract Leviathan of a functioning
Society not a hsian one but a kind of
community that wouldn't have forgotten
the dead so
easily but must a fallen God represent
an end or could it also represent a new
beginning though less common there are
stories where a God's death brings new
life they remain serving as a foundation
upon which something new is built the
Marvel Comic City of nowhere is built in
the skull of a fallen Celestial
basically that universe is equivalent of
a God in the animated series The ow
house an entire civilization thrives on
the bones of a still rotting deity I've
said the word rot a bunch in this video
but in nature rotting isn't something
inherently negative the decomposing
remains of a leviathan like a whale can
feed other life forms for years even
decades such events are called whale
Falls and while I talk more about them
in my video on dead worlds it's worth
reiterating just how much life these Sea
Gods bring to the ocean floor their
skeletons becoming miniature ecosystems
has such a life form even
died but there is another kind of Godly
skeleton that produces another kind of
rot the eeriest region in the game
subnotica is the Lost River a noxious
environment flooded with toxic Brine and
at the center of this Fallout are the
bones of the gargantuan Leviathan a
creature so much larger than the other
in-game life forms it borders on the
Divine there's a sense that the
leviathan's decomposition is what's
creating this poisonous brine that its
power still haunts the environment even
after death but even here there are
creatures that have adapted to this
Briny Wasteland in fact some species
seem to flourish down here their entire
life cycle tied to these pestilent
remains life upon such a polluted
adversarial Leviathan is a struggle it's
unpleasant but it's still a
life on Earth polluted holy sights are
rarely abandoned by the people who
worship them there are no statistics on
how many bodies of water or mountains
have been contaminated over the years
but a quick search shows you the numbers
are in the hundreds if not the thousands
many of these sites are still regularly
visited by individuals who must risk
their own health to continue their way
of life and most of these sacred
landmarks are far from Beyond saving
even Everest despite the severity of its
trash accumulation could be made into a
healthy region once more but it would
require effort a change in the way these
places are unprotected it would require
struggle hyperlight Drifter is a game
about fighting for your life no matter
the conditions or the Fallen Titans
before you at least I think that's what
it's about see Hyperlite Drifter doesn't
contain a single line of dialogue
communicating its themes entirely
through Visual and environmental
storytelling and the visuals that leave
the biggest impact are easily the
remains of the Titans these immense
beings lie scattered throughout the
world and their presence is well it's
disheartening to say the least because
there is a rot a sickness slowly
overtaking the character you play as
seemingly related to whatever wiped out
the Titans though there's evidence the
Titans weren't the nicest creatures if
these beings these gods have all
perished what chance do you
have the theme of hyperlight Drifter is
rooted in personal experience lead
designer Alex Preston was born with a
deteriorating heart disease which he
cites as an inspiration for the game's
presentation you can also see this in
the title of the game Studio heart
machine and in the giant literal Titan
heart you can find that despite being
robbed of a body continues to beat like
the drowned giant one of the Titans has
been disrespectfully cut into pieces and
yet its fractured parts continue to
function Alex Preston who is still
making games by the way knew Hyperlite
Drifter might be his last ever project
and yet he pushed through and created
something that will last into the
future at the end of the drowned giant
the narrator is surprised to find some
of the being's Bones have become part of
the Town its scattered remains becoming
structures and supports for houses
though the giant is gone its influence
is not it reminds me of a story in Norse
mythology the only briefly mentioned in
God of War in the original Norse myth
there's another giant turned Divine
corpse called yamir following his death
yamir's body becomes the foundation for
the entire world out of yamir's Flesh
was fashion the earth and the mountains
were made of his bones the sky from the
cold Frost giant skull and the ocean out
of his blood something can still be made
from the body of a fallen Leviathan even
if it isn't the same as it once
was maybe it's wrong of me to wish levas
had stayed the same I don't know what
life he might have nurtured what
ecosystems fed upon his remains levas
still exists both in my memories and on
my Wii if I turn it back on because he's
from a video game but you know metaphor
the Leviathan of civilization also still
endures though much of breath of the
Wild's world has been destroyed there
are pockets of survivors from which a
community could reemerge maybe that
society would rever levas not for the
god of the Skies he once was but for the
modest shelter his remains now
offer Zelda games have always had a
sense of decaying Divinity that the land
itself was once something sacred and is
now decomposing even the brightest
titles can capture this feeling but
there's also a consistent sense that not
All Is Lost that the world can still be
rebuilt on the bones of what came before
the giant is still alive for me the
narrator States at the end of the
drowned giant I often dream of his
resurrection a Colossus striding through
the streets of town picking up the
fragments of himself on his return
Journey to the
Sea and as always thanks for watching if
you enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next
[Music]
video